ils vont mais parce que j'ai bouffé min
non non je m'en fais des bonnes femmes à
q vous nous raconter ce que vous allez
recevoir et vous faire un peu comme à
midi à kehl a véritablement vous êtes
rendu compte vous étiez sur deux est pas
mal
[Applaudissements]
j'imagine qu'on a la tête qui fourmille
de projets et d'idées on peut pas dormir
on est tout le temps à me coucher
d'ailleurs avec vous comme peut-être
qu'il faut me conneries il va dîner avec
des chirurgiens qui m'ont demandé de
vous demander si vous aviez fait cet été
une opération de chirurgie esthétique
l'algérien fait vrai d'accord tu as vu
mon ex thé pour eux impossible d'après
une telle perfection saisi le meilleur
moment à las vegas moi ça restera mais
jusqu'à la fin de mes jours
comme vous êtes il a été enfermé en
dehors de sa chance et bon pour être
obligés de traverser tout l'hôtel en
petit slip aller chercher les clés à
l'accueil et sont les bonnes femmes tout
le monde me regardait passer mais comme
un ovni
j'ai adoré leur regard s est marié 40
ans tu annonçant le meilleur moment de
ta vie c'est quand
je suis content avec toutes les aides
jeu tout s'entend bien c'est vrai que
tenter peillon c'est pas des accès est à
fond huit mois huit civils fois je
t'aime tu m'aimes of différentes ouais
ouais en 2010
[Applaudissements]
la maîtresse du moins est-ce qu'à des
gens pour aider voire des années sur le
plateau tpm paix quand j'avais été sont
déjà venu sur le plateau de thé pmp il y
en a qui disent oui sans lever la main
comme ça et je vois pas et je le redis
je leur ai fait un tour de magie
incroyable ils sont tous mis de vos
manques on la queue leu leu et j'ai fait
un parent à gauche ce cas mais vu les
1000 sont ceux qui étaient venus ici et
à droite ce qui était pas venu comme ça
je me suis planté que dans non il y
avait douze qui étaient venus une
émission comment je les ai vus moi je
les ai trouvés étaient déjà venus avait
encore des étoiles dans les yeux de nous
avoir vus
il y mathy elle refuse catégoriquement
de payer ces stations stationnement au
parc m c'est trop nord
[Applaudissements]
on n'y apprend pas le métro connais pas
ça me amel bent liban
[Applaudissements]
je souhaitais pas malade et passera les
trois enfants des classes c'est votre
plus mauvaise et michou aller faire un
tour à l'est